[Musik]
das problem
sind die
leicht verfehlt
sie stehen unter druck toni milanese und
340 weitere angestellte der
schweizerischen radio und
fernsehgesellschaft srg
sie kommen aus allen sprachregionen
unseres landes um in sotschi gemeinsam
eine mission zu erfüllen
diese reportage handelt von menschen die
im hintergrund arbeiten aber ohne sie
wäre es nicht möglich das größte projekt
zustimmen dass die scg in angriff
genommen hat
[Musik]
vier wochen vor beginn der olympischen
winterspiele
toni milanese ist hat einem tagen
russland er hat schlecht geschlafen auf
dem 39-jährigen lastet eine große
verantwortung
aus technischer leiter ist er für die
planung und den aufbau des srg
großprojektes zuständig
zwei jahre intensive planung liegen
hinter ihm
diese kolossale bau wurde extra für die
medien gebaut
nicoli ärger ist eine der wenigen die
bereits vor ort sind sie ist für die
administration und logistik zuständig
für recherchen waren beide schon
mehrmals in sotschi
haben wir natürlich wichtig viel also
einerseits hat er
mir persönlich
gefällt die olympischen spiele das ist
sport event und ist und durch die andere
sieht wohl politisch ist wo sich nicht
mir mein verständnis von
politik entspricht natürlich mit einem
jahr
in diesen räumen wird die technik für
radio fernsehen und online medien
aufgebaut und zwar für alle vier
sprachregionen der schweiz
50 tonnen material wurden dafür nach
sotschi transportiert
[Musik]
die hockey gebracht
hat sie nötig sein soll ist für dieses
verbotes und nicht macht dann aber ich
kann es gedankt wir bringen so schnell
dienen und
für neue mitarbeiter und dafür alle
anderen im sommer natürlich schweizer
mit der schuld geht das ist dass
toni vermisst eine kiste mit wichtigem
inhalt
der günther gesagt sie ist nicht vor
lauter worden
bis 7
er ist einer der auf jedes dritte achtet
ob jetzt fehlt ihm ausgerechnet jene
kiste in der sich die videowand für die
technische überwachung befindet
noch gehört der olympiapark den
streunenden hunden ja und fast ein wenig
auch mir zwar bin ich ein sportverein
aber gegenüber diesen teuersten spieler
aller zeiten habe ich gemischte gefühle
[Musik]
von korruption hörte ich von ausbeutung
der arbeiter von zwangsumsiedlungen
wegen der vielen neubauten
[Musik]
ich weiß dass jeder meine schritte
beobachtet wird
immer wieder kontrollieren mich
sicherheitsleute die russische
staatsgewalt ist allgegenwärtig und doch
hat putins macht grenzen den beweis
dafür finde ich unmittelbar neben dem
olympiastadion ein kuriosum gut
versteckt hinter bäumen
auf dem friedhof liegen angehörige der
religiösen minderheit begraben so
genannte altgläubiger eigentlich war
geplant die gräber zu beseitigen durch
die einwohner gingen auf die barrikaden
die regierung konnte die wogen glätten
indem sie dem willen des volkes nach
gabe
ganz in der nähe steht das house of
switzerland der schweizerische
aussenministerium eda und die sg teilen
sich die räume
die beiden beleuchter heinz couch und
michael kuhn bringen das licht in den
holzbau
das ist zum teil verhoben aber das ist
schon bewusst dass wir uns gerne an die
olympischen spiele
im sf-studio hängen die beiden die
scheinwerfer auf
heinz gestört das keineswegs dass sie
später andere im rampenlicht stehen
werden die moderatoren
werden sehr wohl ist mir sehr schwer
gemacht haben
als sie zertreten und sie wurde ständig
das ist
wichtig wenn man so lange dort ist
das angeschafft
toni milanese ist erleichtert die
fehlende kiste mit der videowand wurde
gefunden sie befand sich in einem
zwischenlager in russland
in zwölf geist gegangen wäre
hätte ich nicht verstanden
weitere techniker aus der schweiz hin zu
heben eingetroffen
viel spaß
[Musik]
so schwer die ganz gut sowieso nicht
mehr
[Musik]
super
geschafft oder fast
[Musik]
wissen wir noch nicht genau wie das
die erste leitung in die schweiz steht
die lauberhornabfahrt kanitz live in
sotschi verfolgt werden
die materie
schuld dass man warte da weil wir eine
achtung jetzt ist der moment
er war
in den fensterlosen räumen ist es kühl
nur gerade 14 grad die klima und lage
funktioniert noch nicht richtig sie
schon da so teamarzt
vor allem am anfang braucht man dann
gerne schnell ohne shalom luft schützt
und der frühesten und dann
wahrscheinlich weil wir arbeiten mit den
an es genügt dass eine so eine kleine
erkältung hat sich eine frage verteilt
sind alles mehr oder weniger eingesteckt
ja
noch ein paar kabel miteinander
verbinden dann glimmen auch auf der
videowand die ersten bilder ich bitte
mir richtig heißen arbeitsplatz für die
schaltung
die ganze finden wenn die trickreiche
genau beschützenden der synode zu
schicken
vom biathlon zum trio identische
arbeitsplatz hand und wir sind entsetzt
wieder anzieht werden die spiele am
morgen am aldi 80 morgen an der
motorhaube
[Musik]
hallo
sport moderatorin daniela milanese ist
tonis ehefrau der gemeinsame sohn wächst
zweisprachig auf sein vater ist
italiener
fragen wir jetzt die ganze die man mit
der blüte momentum jetzt einfach sicher
zurück zum 10
ja das liegt eben die frau denn strom
ist sie natürlich ganz frisch
auch mein 15 tage in russland verläuft
gleich wie fast alle bisherigen mit
dauerregen
die wirtschaft krasnaja poljana liegt 40
kilometer vom olympiapark entfernt sie
ist ausgangspunkt für die ski alpin
wettkämpfen
noch vor fünf jahren stand hier kein
einziges haus gebaut wurden hotels
kongress häuser ladenlokale
ein blick hinter die fassaden zeigt es
wird bis zur letzten sekunde gearbeitet
der viele regen setzte im schnee oben im
zielgelände der abfahrtspiste rosa
kultur zu
das ist billiger
er ist regisseur und verantwortlich für
die weltweite betreuung der schülerinnen
gerade erfuhren unangenehmes die russen
haben einige der kamera proteste am
falschen ort aufgestellt
ist kann man auch eine druckstelle und
unternahm jetzt so viel machen wir das
projekt umbau verlängerung geführt oder
ganz abbrechen würde setzt mit der
potash fahrrädern und klug dass man hier
keine lösung die sofort also ich das
möglich ich hatte eine tage machte seite
mit ihnen ganz auf seiten drei meter
hindernis staaten und den muslimen vor
zwei und das nie im leben zweier
menschen
jetzt fahre ich auf dem richtigen weg
sind falsch und es hat noch sieben
bei fernsehübertragungen von skirennen
haben die schweizer viel erfahrung
deshalb hat die srg bereits zum dritten
mal denn auf dauer behalten dass welt
signal für die alpin wettkämpfen zu
produzieren
macht es natürlich auch stolz aber ich
bin eine die ich das ist super team ich
bin nur so gut wie der liegenschaft
durch hundertprozentiges
unten erreichen vertraute materialwagen
erziele rosa kultur
100 leute arbeiten allein für die ski
alpin übertragung viele von ihnen waren
schon mehrmals an olympischen spielen im
einsatz so auch beni giger
erst noch ein bisschen spiels in lila
haben auch sie intensivieren und da bin
ich als koch bewegt sie
der ganztag und damit die bürger dafür
jetzt einen schlitz mittagessen machen
und und kuchen
ja du ich glaub protest ist nützlich ich
glaube da war ich schon
längst hat er den sprung vom kabelträger
zum regisseure live sportübertragungen
geschafft talent und willi machten ihn
zu einem der besten seines fachs
im olympiapark kommt leben ins haus auf
switzerland
der bau des studios ist chefsache
derweil drückt stein dafür monitor ist
noch wissen wie sie die rentendauer
der feldmann vorhand das
nachstehend eine
stimme
[Musik]
ein sehr wichtiger moment hergestellt
aber so dass man das machen also erst
mal live sony studio großen wohl in
raschem abschaltung zweier leitet das
genau
ja ich glaube schon also als vier cent
jetzt einmal und jetzt wenn sie
verschiedene steht magna allerdings sind
sie
wie das ganze regelwerk gilt mit der
musik oder nach einem
danke
zwei wochen vor spielbeginn trifft
roland megger lanes oci1 fse
gesamtleiter für grossanlässe zu den
kosten kann er nicht sagen weil es ein
stillhalteabkommen mit den
vertragspartnern gibt von allen ländern
steht die spd mit ihrer medienaufgebot
und fünfter stelle dieser aufwand sei
viel zu gross wird in der schweiz von
einigen kritisiert
und
eine breite von tammo schweizer
athletinnen und athleten sehr große
medaillenchancen
und dann ist der sonderfall olympia wo
man muss gesehen das von morgen früher
bissig sportwettkampf laufe vieles läuft
parallel und dann braucht man einfach
gewisse art von
leute vor ort braucht es jetzt vor allem
auf den skipisten
russische arbeiter bauen die fouls
platzierten podeste um zum glück sind es
nur deren sechs von insgesamt 70
ein problem gelöst und schon wartet das
nächste unterhalb der skipisten die
organisatoren der spiele sind mit der
bereitstellung der technik sind dazu
in regie wagen für die produktion der
ski alpin rennen sind die leitungen zwar
vorhanden allerdings geht auch hier
nichts in der nacht zuvor hat eine
lawine die glasfaserkabel amberg und
zerrissen
und wenn wir die blicke und zwei
mitstreiter im schnee aussieht hält die
im regen oder regen wir der natur ist
praktisch unmöglich und es macht einfach
wahnsinn also 14 kabel je zwölf fordere
die ihn also zwölf mal 24 us regierung
glaube ich habe und wenn man kein eine
achse sein zum bergheimer kapitel dem
ziel also nützt alles nichts solange die
glasfasern der
branche bisschen deutlicher buch
nur noch vier tage bis zum start der
olympischen spiele
im medienhaus des olympiaparks sind die
rechtlichen angestellten der es ag
eingetroffen
alle 340 leute sind jetzt da sie kommen
aus der ganzen schweiz und arbeiten für
radio fernsehen und multimedia
ganz einfach sagt manchmal orienté als
ich ankam stellte ich den computer an
und es funktionierte die technik hautnah
hause ausgezeichnete arbeit geleistet
zwar haben die techniker noch nicht
jedes problem gelöst aber fast alles ist
betriebsbereit
[Musik]
so ist es mir nun möglich diese
reportage zusammen mit video editor
tolga düren direkt vor ort zu schneiden
[Musik]
nach wochenlangem regen zeigt sich kurz
vor dem beginn der spiele die sonne
[Musik]
morgen ist die eröffnungsfeier
spätestens dann müssen alle technischen
probleme gelöst seien
weniger kann also im rallye-wagen schon
bald die fernsehbilder live
choreografieren aber hinter ihm und
seinem team liegt eine nervenaufreibende
zeit
am hang extrem wirtschaften müsse vor
allem hand aber muss er vor der schufa
blues zum teil jetzt du immer etwas nach
auf dem zielgruppe und wo mueller stahl
kunststoff erkannt sind die kabel nach
coburg kommt jetzt aber müsse in der
nacht in ein riesen aktion bekommt seine
sätze und die bz mega froh dass man
jetzt die ersten bilder gesehen bin ich
guter dinge
[Musik]
heute beginnen die olympischen
winterspiele
radio télévision suisse romande bereits
auf sendung
moderiert für rtl
gleich nebenan die regie des
deutschschweizer fernsehens
[Musik]
sonst herzlich willkommen
vier tage und
das ist die moral dieser geschichte
im rampenlicht kann nur stehen bei von
anderen ausgeleuchtet wird
[Musik]